it's time for screen junkies boobie
bytes
uh you guys welcome to movie fights
we're doing it yet again
BAM coming at you we have an exciting
show for you today let's go ahead and
without any further ado meet our
fighters first you know Maz the pit boss
also his emotional support animal is a
pork welcome to the show
Ken naps are great to be back there has
been some changes here that I'm yeah I
love I can outpace I am ready though I
did bring a small thing of Apple raisin
bourbon chatting this is performance
enhancing for him I declare shenanigans
is there a drunk movie fights legend and
I've checked all the rules and
everything there's no rule that says you
can't be drunk during regular movie
fights okay well you know out of
fairness for a lot of people in the room
including Spencer I'm gonna I'm gonna
abstain or should I need it or share
might be the way to go Ken it is
fantastic to have you back brother
thanks for being here
and his opponent he is probably he might
be drunk he might be on some sort of
substance as life man just life
that's the secret just high on life he's
a funny son of a gun he's a head writer
of honest trailers etc welcome Spencer
Gilbert good to be here we won't be able
to see ya please don't sit please don't
say I might check when the camera goes
back oh yeah no they're hidden panels
there's there's like a whole like Eyes
Wide Shut thing be hot right behind that
weird wall change the backdrop here and
I left a Seinfeld DVD collection back
there what's yours is now mine screen
junkies where your collectibles
disappear so for those of you have not
been with us before let me remind you
how this works we have two fighters we
have three questions in our regular
rounds and then we have a four question
speed round today it'll be judged by
three judges myself and the
two judges over there let's meet our
fact checker mr. dan Merle hello Dan
what's going on nothing actually a lot
yeah nothing sounds good for the so yeah
nothing just telling how um what what's
what's your spirit animal dan what's my
spirit animal yeah any number of things
any number of things Dan thank you for
holding it down on the facts so Dan and
I will be weighing in with our opinions
if we are tied 1-1 we are going to go to
you the audience to decide and that will
be through speaking through mr. Billy
biz Patterson what's up Billy biz what's
going on
Danielle's on assignment this week when
you need someone here and make sure that
this game stays as rigged as it does so
I will be here I'm just kidding stop it
so there's an eye card right up here
somewhere in this general vicinity if
you want to vote in the rounds which we
wants you to vote in the rounds go down
to the bottom of the video you'll see a
little gear icon click it turn your
annotations on and off if you have no
idea what I'm talking about
all of this is in the description of the
video you can read it every single round
and you'll never be lost
fantastic all so Danielle was like in
lockstep with me on this Billy I'm gonna
need you to be on the lookout for
dankmemes but I do glorious gifts okay I
I always appreciate going through your
dank memes after the fight I just you
know by myself when I get home I sip
some tea and look at your panel so enjoy
2015 I mean everyone loves memes how
should I describe the memes then Spencer
you tell me describe the memes ask a
millennial and the wrong guy all right
well we got all dudes here this show
definitely does not pass the Bechdel
test today but we will be having plenty
of fun either way and what do you say we
kick this sucker off with the first
question round number one
maybe just JT that's sick package
[Music]
oh yeah jte thank you for that package
the best package in the biz jte kidnap
suck are you ready I am ready sir
hell yeah Spencer Gilbert you want to do
this ready why not let's see question
number one should Disney stop making
Star Wars movies after episode 9 Wow
you know what we're gonna answer that
question right here right now and let's
start with Ken nap sock preposterous
preposterous I says says the 41 year old
man and his Darth Vader suit and a kylo
Ren shirt and I know I know you're
thinking well of course you're gonna say
it sir you probably have a pork pillow I
don't yet but I might here's the thing
and I know sweaty we're gonna get into
it and you're gonna throw some Barb's at
me and I love them oh you're the
funniest man in the world I know but
here's here's the truth
should they yes number one it's good
business have you seen what these money
these money makers have done absolutely
so if you're sitting there some high
tower and you're wondering should we
continue to do these well they might be
creatively bankrupt but you know what
we're not gonna be bankrupt we're going
to make more Star Wars absolutely you're
going to make more and the second reason
why you need to do this we are nowhere
near done telling Star Wars stories now
you might think wow we're getting Han
Solo there's been rumors of an obi-wan
movie uh do we need a Jabba the Hutt
underworld movie yeah maybe some people
don't maybe some people don't but there
is a giant galaxy that is was expanded
years ago and even though that stuff is
now legends we have new cannon to play
with and we're are learning things what
Star Wars rebels is teaching us about
the force the nature of the force if
you're we're learning about the
formation the rebellion that's one of
the great things rogue one and the rogue
one novel did we are introducing
eventually soon if they continue making
movies new eras of Star Wars
storytelling whether it be back in the
Old Republic whether it be off in the
Unknown Regions there's a lot to
creatively mind there and even if you go
back to something like an obi-wan Kenobi
movie there are stories to tell emotions
and themes to play around with there and
that's number two and number three we're
letting transformers and Fast and the
Furious still go but the idea of cutting
off star wars because maybe someone did
like what they do Luke Skywalker or we
don't want to know how Joe Jabba rose to
power in the criminal underworld no
that's that's that is also preposterous
this is Star Wars it has been around for
now 40-plus years it will continue to be
around one way or another and the idea
of new stories is a good idea he doesn't
want it to go anywhere Spencer where do
you stand on it you know you mentioned
creatively mind and that's a perfect
metaphor this is a mine this is a strip
mine this has been picked clean this is
a corpse that has been absolutely
shredded for any interesting nugget
already I'll go even further than should
it make episode I'd stop production on
Episode nine throw out solo I want every
Star Wars Battlefront to loot box to
just pop up with a thing that says call
your mother this franchise needs to stop
well it still got any magic left in it
and it comes down to a fundamental
question Ken it's it better to burn out
or fade away you know that's what we're
coming down to it I would rather have
Star Wars have had a good run and have
gone out with a little bit left in the
tank than to get put in this unwinnable
toxic creative bind that it's in today
when you stick to the formula when you
give the fans what they want you get
something boring you get something
predictable you get the same old Star
Wars you get another lightsaber fight
you get another Death Star trench run
you get another I'm good then I'm bad
now I'm a Skywalker Dharma solo you get
the same old same old if you deviate
from that you get the big Rick and Morty
Szechuan sauce fan meltdown I'm like I
want it to be the way I want it they're
in a Kobayashi Maru creative wise and
they cannot escape from it so you know
instead of what's going to happen which
is getting a Star Wars every single year
until they've explored every single
backstory of every single button on Han
Solo's vest let's just pull the plug
let's just make some room for some new
magic and re-experience the magic of
Star Wars again in something other than
Star Wars all right better to burn out
than fade away Neil Young sure fight it
out fellas I mean I appreciate the
reference to a great moment in Jack
Black's character and high-fidelity need
to fade away question there too but look
strip-mine corpse to you to you in a
Slytherin shirt absolutely but to me and
Mike I love red shirt no I'm speaking
for a lot of people now we should
probably put that aside I I I'm a Star
Wars dork this I used to get beat up on
the play
in the 80s WOM living in a golden age I
probably got beat up by guys like you
I'm sure
and your Slytherin shirt oh yeah it was
when in popularity contest by beat
reading Harry Potter you don't end up
it's like an 18 year old in digital
media if you had a good childhood I
don't think you don't end up here yeah
you don't appear but here like no 9 that
is that it that is is crazy tuck there
is a lot again to a lot of people you
they might be Gertie Spencer's right
this is creatively minded strip-mined
like a spice my nan castle all right get
that reference yeah I'm sure you do but
they're all be a movie about it we're
about to see it many things and you're
right the fandom lot of phantoms are
toxic that's no reason to turn away from
it Empire was looked down upon in 1980
it's now the standard-bearer what we do
episode 8 will I think stand the test of
time I absolutely love the movie full
disclosure alright so in terms of being
stripped mind of creativity there's
still great minds telling great stories
there but they're going to keep telling
those stories until they're no longer
great and let's end it now while there's
still questions to be answered well we
can still fill in the blanks with our
own imagination I just think that
because this is now Disney if the
question was should Disney stop making
Star Wars movies after episode 9 this is
such a cynical sick place for Star Wars
to end up stars is about a small group
of independently minded rebels fighting
against the big monolithic evil empire
what fits that better than Disney in
2018 this is a company that crushes
dissent there's a company that tried to
patent Dios de los Muertos for it for
cocoa this is a sick place for Star Wars
supposedly about like the magic of the
underdog to end up this is now a product
on a giant Excel spreadsheet across Bob
iger's desk it's like well we know the
Star Wars revenues are down 3.4% over
quarterly projections this is
antithetical to the message of the
film's themselves but thankfully Bob
Iger is not making these films he's
certainly dropping new scoops on
conference calls the number one source
for Star Wars news is Bob iger's
conference calls but you know it is it
is people like Rian Johnson it is Dan
and Dave and they're gonna bring in some
great people behind it it is Dave Filoni
who just told pure poetry and Star Wars
rebels who can now move into other
projects and and projects within Star
Wars universe
it is the story group with Leland Chee
carry-back Harry Hart who leads
Pablo Hidalgo the keeper of all the
Canon Matt Martin a lot of people like
that who are telling great stories about
the magic of storytelling by committee
Star Wars used to be George Lucas's baby
and at least for all his faults Elisa's
was consistent now you have Brian
Johnson with his idea of Star Wars and
you have Jay James with his idea of
stars these things don't mix anymore
there's no cohesive creative vision
aside from what is the product for 2020
2021 22 23 it that that that is a
cynical way to look at it I'm not saying
you're cynical Spencer though I mean
I've I've been to New York with you too
you're cynical I get it no it is not
necessarily that yes was there a little
bit of a weird handoff from Abrams to
Johnson back to now Abrams yeah I'm sure
absolutely but I don't want Star Wars to
be cookie cutter I love and respect what
Marvel has done that MCU we all love and
clearly get paid from I love that Feige
has a big plan but I don't want I want
Star Wars to be the poetry that George
Lucas did intend it to be George decided
to sell it off that that's his decision
it was it was wasn't going anywhere at
that point though he did have the idea
to make standalone films he wanted to
make a solo film with Lawrence Kasdan a
long time ago that's something that's in
his wheelhouse and you're right the
prequels show that if you go off and
tell weird Star Wars stories you you
will find new ways to to teach the 12
year olds of the next generation well
you said you don't want to become cookie
cutter but there's no way that it can't
become cookie cutter if you have one of
these every single year that when this
becomes a product like it you're a slave
to the schedule not to the material yeah
you that's why you have people dropping
off of these things left and right is
because they have to hit the deadline
and they don't have time to hit pause
and maybe think it over and develop it
more it took George Lucas you probably
know better than I do like four years
and 17 drafts to write the first Star
Wars movie they were writing rogue one
in post-production they're writing
editing they're like maybe Darth Vader
should pop out at the end and kill
everyone these are things that are just
going to be watered down and just
stretched thin until they just go out
like a fart in its star just let me ask
you Spencer are you asking for just less
Star Wars movies instead of one on sale
in Disney's hands they are going to keep
going until we just stop showing up and
just they just lose all their flavor and
all their magic so
given the alternative pull that plug cut
the cord and can let me ask you
so you mentioned it's good business he
said they're only in it for the revenue
how would you respond to that sure some
of the bigwigs Disney but you know
Disney is the one that's that's just
saying Lucasfilm go make this and
there's passionate Star Wars fans that
looks whim and at this point everything
is fanfiction if it's not made from
George Lucas that that's true but and
just some of the stuff I'll acknowledge
some of the stuff what you're saying
Spencer rogue one they had to bring a
Tony Gilroy okay yeah absolutely we got
rid of track to vatra Varro Lord Miller
but that's not necessarily a reason to
pull up shop they wanted to get it right
and yeah it's modern filmmaking
we got a release date we got a hit we
got a poster release date we got a hit
that's just disappointing yeah George
Lucas himself he always fought those big
entities George was about the rebels
fighting that he was himself he's he's
the most independent billionaire movie
storyteller in the world that's what it
is but here's the thing right now I get
it
episode 8 just came out it caused some
problems solos around the corner again I
I'm looking forward to it I understand
we need another solo film tell you what
episode 9 is 18 months or so after Han
Solo comes out by this time December
1990 December 2019 rolls around or 1919
the black socks people fans are gonna be
rabid they're gonna be frothing at the
mouth we need episode 9 the excitement
will build in and every time you sit
down in that theater as generations pass
this on the next generation will be like
there's a new Star Wars film let's go
see a long time ago in the galaxy far
far away but there's no
intergenerational hand off when it's
every single year is this isn't every
generation gets their own Star Wars this
is Star Wars it's just a fact of life
like death and taxes now this just is
it's just not special anymore and you
mentioned modern filmmaking yeah
Star Wars for all of its virtues created
the state of modern filmmaking as we
know it today because of its success
it's a victim of its own success because
now every studio they just want the big
special effects heavy blockbuster they
they want the pre-sold universe the
sixth movie arc the merchandising tie-in
this is all thanks to Star Wars yes sir
yeah I'm gonna ask you to
into the camera and pretend it is a
child of seven years old who loves Star
Wars this child loves Star Wars tell him
that Star Wars is going bye-bye forever
you know what son for kylo Ren once said
the past must die kill it if you have to
die get that right he did I'll let you
finish okay
so for a new life to sprout other things
have to take the hit and in your case
it's the thing you love it's Star Wars
and I think you think you love Star Wars
but you don't what you love is the
feeling of discovery of the unknown of
imagination of hope and you'll find that
in other places
star wars ain't gonna give it to you
anymore the first hits always the best
and then you're just chasing that high
for the rest of your life till you're
unfit no passed out in a gas station
parking lot that took a dark turn Ken
I'm gonna throw you the same challenge
except you are going to tell a jaded
redditor why Star Wars should stay
around and be now and forever all right
come here all right put your sweat pants
back on reason that you took to the
internet which is you were inspired at
one point by fandom you were inspired by
the stories it took you beyond the stars
and then you decided to get a username
and then debate people about whether or
not Chewbacca should have been killed by
a moon or not or whether or not Luke
should have ignited his green lightsaber
he shouldn't have it's not necessary
Ryan took us to a new level here's the
thing this isn't necessarily just for
you it is a bigger thing this is out of
your hands Star Wars can never be put
back into the box it will never be that
fresh thing we saw in 1977 it will now
be multi-layered it will now grow it
will now expand and you one day one day
if you can afford the money you save up
and you get a bride sent to you in a box
you're gonna be able to make a child
you're gonna be able to make a child and
you just want to pass on the joy that
you once had you once had and there's
going to be a Star Wars film every year
and when you get down in that theater
and the lights go down and you're
chomping on that hotdog and you're
eating that popcorn in your diabetes is
growing you are gonna see the Lucasfilm
logo you're gonna see a long time ago
a galaxy far far away and you will get
excited because I'm like what kylo said
it didn't mean kill the past
bury it he meant learn from the past
that's the purpose that's the point a
lot of what waves going through so yeah
little things you're commenting on if
we're gonna learn from it we're gonna
make better stories from here on out
time wow what a battle gentlemen I think
it's easier to talk to a child that no
one said this was gonna be easy I'm good
Lars and the real girl reference in
there by the way fellas
this was quite a collision quite a
collision and you both came out swinging
and you both uh you were not pulling
punches can you you got me excited with
the extended universe and which now the
Canon learning about the rebellion
forces learning about job there are
definitely bounty hunters I want to
learn more about but then some of your
arguments like when you're the first
tentpole of your argument was that it's
good business and I feel like you didn't
really combat Spencer's point about it
being about the revenue about Disney
like really just micromanaging quarterly
earnings of Star Wars toys and etc and
then you're talking about George Lucas's
poetry and Spencer talked about how this
is somewhat to paraphrase just
Frankenstein nowadays with the different
people telling the stories and there
isn't as much consistency and I feel
like we are experiencing a little Star
Wars fatigue you got me excited I felt
your passion but I feel like Spencer had
the more logical salvo so I give it to
Spencer
that's one for Spencer dancer like are
bad and you should feel bad about them
dan yes yes a couple of just fact check
things Ken there is a pork plush pillow
buddy and throw blanket said available
on Amazon for $40 but hurry there are
only nine left in stock I did admire
Spencer using the Star Trek Kobayashi
Maru metaphor for Star Wars fandom a
nice mixture of the two
premiere sci-fi franchises it's better
to burn out than to fade away it is a
Neil Young line it's from the acoustic
version of my my hey hey
Disney today claimed over two dozen new
release dates through 2023 including 19
dates for untitled live-action movies
there are currently only two confirmed
Star Wars movies on their schedule solo
and episode 9 kylo ren's quote was let
the past die kill it if you have to this
was a Clash of the Titans this was this
this really was two people with very
compelling arguments the it was really a
generational argument versus you're both
in a way pleading for the future of
America and the world really in general
and won't someone think of the children
yeah I don't know I feel like Ken was
you were so passionate but even in your
closing just your appeal was it'll never
be that thing that fresh thing again
from 1977 like it will never be the
thing that came fresh out of the box and
as a closer that's that kind of swayed
me the Spencer side cuz it's it's
acknowledging that it will never again
be new and fresh and shiny and I think
that Spencer's arguments about you know
finding inspiration elsewhere in other
places and it's time to move on
connected to me more deeply so I will
have to side with Spencer though can I
admire your passion for the film and the
subject matter Spencer takes it that
means they're officially they're
officially will be no more Star Wars
from Disney Billy Patterson tell us what
the social settle powering up yeah if
you can believe it I had to keep
checking this the poll was 50/50 so I
would not have been any help to you Wow
is dead split I mean literally it's the
Internet and we're talking about Star
Wars are we surprised I mean Sam said
I'm with Spencer J Gilbert unto order 66
these Star Wars movies and then Thomas
said I hate Star Wars so I say Disney
should make millions of more Star Wars
movies that's the fandom they're you
know that's fans today I hate it so just
what kind of
pretzel logic is that I think they liked
their fans that love to watch things
that they hate continue to be hated yeah
so the stream so they can so they can
keep commenting can't imagine hey Billy
yeah were there any dank ass meanest
glorious gifts of Bobby Roode ones
awesome Ken is it still 50/50 the polar
has it now that the judgments are made I
worry that it's gonna be let's just see
yeah it's still pretty close citing a
little bit more with Ken but it doesn't
the protest I respect you guys a
decision thank you sir
let's see question number two what movie
should win Best Picture at the Oscars
ooh the most glamorous night in showbiz
the Academy Awards this weekend yes we
will have video on Monday the grouchy's
tune in for that but what should win
Best Picture
let's start with Spencer Gilbert well
just an opening we're not talking about
what will win which i think is the shape
of water we're talking about what I
think should win that's just a little
film called phantom thread and in
determining this I went back to the very
first Academy Awards and fact check me
on this Dan but there was no best
picture award there were two kind of
similar ones one for outstanding picture
which went to the big-budget success of
the year and one for unique and artistic
production and I think that that is the
criteria I used to evaluate Best Picture
what is the most unique and artistic
movie of the year I think that's what
the award should be for not the most
popular not the most entertaining the
one that was the most different and had
the most to add to films and that for me
was the phantom thread alright thank you
for your opening statement Ken knapsack
and this is this year right films
released in this year yes films that
were released in 2018 no I'm kidding it
just sometimes you know this cake takes
me all to catch up to movie love the
films that are actually nominally
okay I just want to make sure I don't
think crash should win all right
it's a bold statement now my choice is
it's already been mentioned by by
Spencer and I totally agree with Spencer
we're arguing this question not what
weeds and predictions here but I do
believe it is shape of water this was a
beautiful unique awkward let's address
Fischer sex now and inspiring story and
I think it is gamma del Toro doing what
he does best which is these fantastic
worlds and these creatures and these
stories but tied and into something
familiar which is love and loneliness
and longing and a desire to be connected
and then you throw in creepy Michael
Shannon that's always a good thing so my
choice is shape of water fight it out
fellas
they're all good movies this is I really
liked shape water I think it's fantastic
Paul Thomas Anderson fan who is so
there's a you got a really pick nits
here but for me I just have to give
phantom thread the edge because of its
uniqueness and I'll get to that but I
want to just start by saying that but
shape of water just felt kind of
familiar to me it felt like a
beautifully executed fairy tale but
still a fairy tale this is the
Cinderella story this is Free Willy this
is um what's the other one I'm thinking
of Andre that's one of the seal there's
a little mermaid there's any kind of
like unlikely relationship between
Thomas a Tank Engine yet Thomas the Tank
Engine
exactly mighty Joe Young it's a
forbidden love story which can be great
and this was a fantastically executed
one but I just thought it was kind of
predictable beat by beat of like they
would run off together and she would be
you know his queen and they would they
would live happily ever after
and in that respect you know it's about
the timeless power of love and yes that
warms the cold cockles of my heart but
phantom thread was something different
it was a relationship story that was
like kind of complicated at an adult it
was about the weird power struggle
between people in love and the weird
undermining and head games they play
with each other and the collisions of to
like not great people of like a
uncontrollable genius and his muse who's
determined to control her like these are
next I haven't seen played out in film
and I was just fascinated by it because
I really did not know what was gonna
happen next
and that's a fair point and you
mentioned the first Academy Awards I
think that's where the phantom said
Phantom Menace it is this kind of old
style of oscar movie to me it is this
big complicated let's think and ponder
and that's fine again I'm a Paul Thomas
Anderson fan I'm a Daniel day-lewis fan
stay alive I will find you one of the
great moments in film all right so I'm
not here to take that away but what I'm
saying with the shape of water is is
this is it's got performance that people
are talking about and I know it's not
just a popular preference for
performance no I know DDL DBS final role
and my keychain role Sally Hawkins
Richard Jenkins Doug Jones a former
movie fighter here we see we've seen him
there but here it is it is a movie that
is some would consider more progressive
for the world we live in now I don't
want to watch a genius crazy complicated
genius get poisoned or choose to give a
spoiler alert you know you know and
Daryl Hannah takes Tom Hanks back to the
water yeah but guess what what you're
talking about with predictability it's
really about comfort and and story it's
not there's only seven stories in the
world right this is about it's about how
you execute the story a Star Wars fan
would say that you're you're at the
altar of Joseph Campbell right now
there's room for new stories they and
performance-wise Vicky creeps I just got
is it creeps crypts crepes crepes hey
Vicky we apologize for butchering your
name completely it's so fantastic he
plucked her from relative obscurity
going toe-to-toe the best actor of a
generation this is like a rocky Apollo
Creed performance that she is going
scene for scene with him and then like
you talk about the artistic
craftsmanship of it it's good the
craftsmanship is very clear and apparent
on-screen in a shape of water but in
Phantom thread you have these amazing
tracking shots of him going through the
the New Year's Eve party you have the
most crack you have crackling dialogue
you have the best score of the year from
jonny greenwood it's like a twisted a
music box playing underneath the entire
film the costumes I didn't look up any
of this but I assume that they're
accurate
and very cool I'll give you that I
assume the racket the shape water it's
like it's an oscar movie it's a it's a
similar it's a film about how great film
itself is like it's that scene of him
watching a movie in an old-timey movie
theater that was the most pandering
eye-rolling moment of the year for me
that was like I want to win an Oscar he
have the fish man like crying the single
tear because he sees how beautiful the
movies are you have cinematography here
you have music Alexander discipline is
that a you said death blast is that how
you say JT I'm asking the wrong
Alexander we apologize for butchering
your name yeah it captures how to be
alone they captures all those things and
yeah there's a formula to Oscar films
but I also think that's part of the
problem with the Oscars and when when
time passes on yeah maybe we can all sit
down and have a nice plate of vegetables
which is phantom thread we all need
vegetables we should all eat more
vegetables make some Eva's Gigi to give
me that shot there we all need more
vegetables all right but sometimes you
like broccoli with melted cheese on it
and I think that's what the shape of
water is it's just fasting the veg sorry
you were gonna still think about this
movie you're gonna tell other people to
see it I've asked I asked people and
research to ask people like friends of
mine
well phantom threat didn't see it boring
I was born Jennifer Lawrence turned it
off and she is the barometer of what
good movies oh god it is an adult fairy
tale and we still need those stories in
this time and I think this movie this
year it's a perfect time for that kind
of movie we have red vegetables the
Oscars is all about the vegetables who
will cheer for the vegetables if not the
Oscars we need these movies to keep
being made and that's what the Oscars is
all about shape water made over a
hundred million dollars like that's fine
you want the most entertaining movie
award the it's decided by the box-office
by people actually going up to see it
the the Oscars is people in the craft
saluting the best in the craft itself
and the craft of film was not better
served than in any film other than
there's a lot of very red this is not
the question but I would like to hear
from you just so you can help inform me
as to the esteem you hold them the
entirety of the movie what other Oscars
would you give your particular film
Ken let's start with you I would do I
would say Sally Hawkins
formants there I mean come you know not
being able to get a user voice I I think
I would go with musical costume design I
any kind of production Awards any kind
of those awards that are held in like
the Saturday before like that over a
cotillion and at a tea party a lot of
wards there and I I think the writing
and I understand there's more
complicated stories and scripts out
there that's part of the magic of this
how can you tell a timeless tale that we
are we all believe in the fairy tales of
love here but I think Deltora really
really told a great story here Spencer I
mean the obvious one is actor and
actress for Dan day-lewis and Vicki
cribs I think best director for Paul
Thomas Anderson I'm not about giving
legacy awards because I do think that
this is actually his up there with his
best work but this is a guy who cannot
be our next Scorsese cannot be our next
Leo we need to give this guy an Oscar
and give it to him fast this is a it
could it could be up there for best
cinematographer which he also was he was
his own cinematographer and costume
design I mean come on the whole movies
about costume design that's got to be
phantom thread when that's court best
very very meta very much yeah time wow
what a battle we're not gonna know the
real answer till this weekend but we're
gonna figure out this answer right now
Dan Merle yes sir
let's start with you brother yes the
cotillion that Ken referred to as the
Academy's scientific and technical
awards they were held this year on
February 10th hosted by some would say
Oscar snubby Sir Patrick Stewart Spencer
you are correct the original the first
Annual Academy Awards there was a
category called outstanding picture
that's the category that evolved into
what we now call best picture which
Whateley movie wings one not to be
confused with these Steven Weber NBC
sitcom there was another category called
best unique and artistic picture that
went to sunrise by FW Murnau so you are
correct there Spencer there were two
different ones uh this was very
difficult to good choices if you don't
mind should I just did I tell you who
I'm thinking how I do you want to should
i oh okay yeah yeah two good choices
however I believe that
Spencer made the stronger arguing about
why his movie should be recognized and
then the question about what other
Awards it was worthy of I thought he
made a compelling case
so I despite very much loving the shape
of water
idak Spencer made the better argument
for phantom thread and I'm siding with
him so it's 104 Spencer you know what
I completely agree with Ken but for many
of the reasons that Dan mentioned
Spencer went down a list of the that he
talked about the tracking shot in the in
that New Year's party the score of Jonny
Greenwood you also mentioned the score
from your film but I feel like just
Spencer had more specific bullet points
as to what set his film apart but you
did counter with j-law and he got a love
you know like half a point yes you know
it was interesting but at the end of the
day I feel like Spencer had the just
yeah but he had the bullet points in the
specifics and a very difficult argument
I gotta go with Spencer Spencer takes
that point I'm in a hole you know what
you could climb anybody's game yeah I
love Magnolia man I'd get PT a win come
on still anybody's game
Billy biz what's going on on the
Internet
yeah the internet they went the complete
opposite way 70% for the shape of water
they were firmly in the in that campaign
people don't like vegetables yeah not so
much and thank you very much too on
Harris for sending me Thomas the Tank
Engine yeah I would give it to the shape
a lot of our fans okay personally yes
you got it out of the game I'm a little
rusty yeah you know this is a chav
format caliber fighter here yeah it's
the standing cat I know that it's my
tank my ankles do many many a new movie
fighter has collapsed mid-fight so
I mean you're hit to win just to remain
up we have to turn the camera off and
let Scott manse just sit down all right
let's see question numero tres holy
crime okay this is a blind fight and
it's about to get kooky up in here all
right so sometimes you do a blind fight
with one hat today we've got two half
mm-hmm
that's kind of blind like this gonna be
owned all right I need each of you to
pick a name out of each hat please don't
good good I look at them yes you can
look at them okay all right so these
hats all contain Game of Thrones
characters oh Ken and Spencer you are
two major league throw knees want to go
ahead and read us the characters you
have Ken Arya Stark of Winterfell and
her good friend hot pie all right
and who'd you end up with Spenny
Daenerys the unburnt and the Hound all
right so the question in honor of the
announced rush hour four because you
have to do something to honor the
announced okay Chris and Jackie need a
paycheck pitch a game of Thrones
buddy-cop movie in honor of the
announced rush hour Wow I love this
question Spencer
sorry Spencer I'm used to regard me
saying your name and knapsack it's
question number three so we're gonna
start with you all right
the night king in the army the undead
have traveled south of the wall after
breaking through it thanks to the undead
visera and the ice breathing dragon and
he has taken over Westeros snow has
covered the lands all the Great Houses
are in peril
destroyed gone Searcy barely sits on the
throne the house Winterfell how stark it
is scattered about to Daenerys and Jon
Snow are off having icky lovemaking
sessions over down it's at Dragonstone
so the world is now down to two heroes
Arya Stark and her good friend hot pie
as hot pie said himself in season seven
of Game of Thrones he's a survivor he's
gonna be okay
and so's Arya Stark so hot pie and Arya
travel the lands on horseback
hot pie has to take some breaks and they
go secretly from house to house while
the night king rules saying come out and
Ebro to anyone down at what is left at
King's Landing it is up to Arya and hot
pie to travel along the the roads of
Westeros giving hot bread hot pie still
loves making his bread and a fine soup
the keys just to let the ingredients sit
for a little bit and they go forming
secret secret little groups along the
way as they start building up a new army
a new army and the fight whites along
the way they fight White Walkers along
the way they fight the others that's
right they are a new team a new set of
heroes and they're heading straight to
King's Landing
all right a new army built on bread and
soup Spencer yours was too big and to
Game of Thrones this is a buddy cop
movie I'm taking it back to basics let's
just say that this is post Game of
Thrones and that the nurse and the Hound
both lived through it and they've
defeated the night's king and now the
guy do something so they're the gold
cloaks of kings landings two new rookie
recruits one's a former princess who
can't be burnt by fire and the other is
a vigilante who was burnt by fire and
hates it so much their boss Meryn Trant
you know he's always like on their case
you know the hound
Daenerys get in here and they have to
clean the streets of the dirtiest city
in Westeros you know they're a classic
Odd Couple like ones this gruff
disgusting guy the others this imperial
princess there's gonna be so many like I
will drive the horse no I will drive the
horse you know you have all this classic
buddy-cop beats like that you have the
good good cop
bad cop interrogation scene where you
know they got to get some information
out of a guy and and you know daenerys
like throw some fire on him and the
hound recoils and is like oh but then
they bond over their shared love of
chicken you know this is just like a
classic classic Miami Vice like two
people from opposite sides of the tracks
teaming up to take down some
street-level crime look you you you are
you you might be right that I I may be
overreached right it seems like that but
let me tell you something there's a
great buddy cop movie that is set
against the backdrop at the possible end
of the world that's the first men in
black
Will Smith Tommy Lee Jones they're
having their moments they're having this
but they're still out to save the world
find that galaxy that's what's going on
here
imagine a seed of Arya with their sword
like don't I've got backup and you cut
and there's like hot pie like one moment
I'm not done eating this is funny I mean
it's Ari and hot pie hot pie doesn't
have your scene hot pie with the sword
it's good there's gonna be a great
hilarious montage of hot pie learning
he's dropping this sword I can I can
walk around a lot of this that's our hot
pie but we've seen that that's from Game
of Thrones season 3 where they're
rolling around in the carton area not by
we've seen that already this is to two
people who were still waiting for them
to interact and what perfect person to
take the airs out of Daenerys who so
above it on so hoity-toity than the
Hound than the slavering disgusting
hound some of the best moments of his
character arc was when he was paired up
with Sansa so why not pair him up with
an even more elevated version of Sansa
and have them solve crime together
brothel de Bravo alright let's freeze
for one second I'm gonna throw a little
curveball your way your your buddy cops
they got to go undercover to do
something take a moment then tell us how
and what they're they're going
undercover as they're there's a you know
like a weed drug what's a game of
Thrones drug poppy milk of the poppy
melissad milk of the poppy factory is
being run out of a cod egg fish plant
down by the docks you know it's like
disgusting it's gross and and you know
the Hound shows up to go undercover and
is and he's like ratted tattered rags
and a you know he's got his full scarred
face out in all its glory and Daenerys
comes in in like a you know like an
empress gown and he goes like no and
then she comes out in like a more
tasteful like business casual one he's
like no and then she comes back out in
like a like a like overalls with like a
little smudge is like oh man we got to
do this Messiah and then they just roll
around in the mud and like this is there
this is their bonding moment where she
learns to like let her hair down some
fun stuff Ken and we're at the end of
the movie man the night king who is
probably a stark at heart he's on what
is left of the Iron Throne he has
destroyed Cersei she believed in I was
one of the last hopes and so we we it's
almost Sam and Frodo it's getting to
motor it's Ari and hot pot and they have
got to go undercover as White Walkers
and so what do they do
Arya is gonna teach him but hot pie this
is where his skills finally come into
play he's able to make a a cream out of
frosting that he would normally put on
it on a sweet cake and he puts things
like this white kind of glaze all over
them then arias gonna like this and they
go into the red keep the final big
moment is them trying to learn to work
together and his skills and her skills
are coming together to take down the
night time Wow
both super good jobs super nice work
yeah I watch the hell out of both you
both had scenes that I want to watch but
can I like that
I love the men in black reference you're
tying it into some of the great buddy
cop stuff of all time and the antics and
then Spencer painted a great scenario
but I love that hot pie used food like
you used his skill set to go deep-cover
gotta give it to Ken this time around
100 Ken Dan Merle Ken unquestionably
Kate had the best scene of all of the
like I was I was I was thought I'd made
up my mind but why that is a classic
buddy cop scene of antics and tomfoolery
I will say Spencer that if brothel de
brothel isn't the name of your bed and
I'm doing something wrong that has to be
the name Wow I I was so ready to say
Spencer and
can kind of came up with that nugget but
I do think that Spencer nailed the
dynamic better overall between the
characters so even though Ken scene was
the best I have to go with the general
tone and dynamic that Spencer pitched
I'm gonna throw it to the crowd because
I'm having trouble making a decision I
think the voice of the people should
speak because I think I think Spencer
edged it out but it's very close all
right it is one one Billy what do you
got for us this was 50-50 most of it and
then one person pulled ahead at the very
end
please be Jack Shipley has decreed that
it's Arya Stark hot pie any other combos
or movie pitches in there a lot of
people want to see Game of Thrones
people in true detective rather than was
gone for anything other than last
season's truth HBO could just start
doubling up there I'm hoping my hair
xolali saves true detective and it is to
one Spencer over Ken and it's time to
head to the speed round as I drop my pen
so here's how the speed round works
it's 2-1 the first fighter to get four
points takes the game there are four
speed round questions they each get 20
seconds and then 10-second rebuttals the
first person to speak we'll begin our
fight ken are you feeling it I think the
rules are relatively to what I'm
familiar with there all right Spenny
ready to vomit words all right let's do
this question number one what category
should be added to the Oscars most
entertaining best performance capture
Wow all right
we heard most entertaining best
performance capture Spencer you spoke
first begin whenever you're feeling it
this is the flip side to my argument for
phantom thread just as movie vegetables
deserve
reward in their own category movie
sweets deserve their own category this
is a type of filmmaking filmmaking as a
product your Star Wars is your Logan's
your your big franchise movies it's also
a skill this tied universe storytelling
is also its own art form but it's
defferent and its unique from
independent film I absolutely think
that's a good idea it lets be
entertaining but you know what the
Oscars are still about recognizing the
art of motion pictures who said so
yourself so we are not having a problem
they're not break the circuses of the
world the tobe couples of the world are
not getting a chance to break through in
this individual categories like some of
those other movies are they sneak in
return to the king one right so I want
to see them recognized in their own
category and it'll spurn more art but
the Oscar says the telecast has been
dying the ratings going down year every
year this is a way to bring people back
to the fold without like giving you your
token token genre movie - in costume
design or whatever this is a way to give
them all people reason to tune in I
don't I don't need people to tune in I
still want to keep to the history with
the Academy Awards are and performs
capture is the future it's what's going
on it's build what a lot of movies are
built on let's reward that wow you guys
guns blazing for reals
so now Billy has his own vote and let's
start with Billy biz Patterson I loved
both of those arguments but for me I
think I liked Ken's argument more of the
the Oscars are about the arts and the
best in the art of filmmaking and motion
capture he said has become such a big
part of it and we're not recognizing
that so I'm gonna go with Ken yeah one
oh Ken and I thought they both gave
great arguments and just lightning fast
Spencer wanted to make it more
entertaining I felt like Ken rebutted
that beautifully with the return of the
King Academy Award which is a very
populous film and a beautiful well-made
film and Ken's argument swayed me ken
gets the point we are locked up at to
two people all right question number two
of the speed round oh by the way that
last question was submitted by G off
11:06 that's Jeff spelled the Old
English way 11:06 question number two
name two people you'd most want to be in
a Hugh
senator Guy Fieri and Martha Steph
Paltrow Paltrow first I'm gonna go with
oh crap which is on the docket I'm gonna
go with I'm gonna go sorry I'm gonna go
with Salma Hayek and Rupert Everett wait
do I get to choose my position within
the centipede maybe in your argument
okay so so we heard Guy Fieri and guy
and Gwyneth and some on and Rupert
Everett begins whenever you speak well
if I'm at the front of the centipede I
want to be it wanted to be me Gweneth
who's probably a buck fifty but fifteen
soaking wet and then Guy Fieri to carry
the caboose I think if I'm in the middle
which i think is the spirit the question
is intended I want people who have great
diets who nutritious and delicious food
then I would love even second or even
third hand you guys are twisted this
problem can only come from the mind of
lawn Harris there's someone else on if
I'm in the middle
I want Salma Hayek in the front because
look I have a heteronormative male
that's gonna be an experience that I'm
okay with deal with someone behind me
might as well be revered who's probably
more comfortable there than other people
so let's just form this nice symbiotic
training like this life together let's
get crazy kids
there's nothing normative about eating
crap you want to go on a basic survival
flavor and diet purpose that's why you
need someone who found in goop who
drinks toxified
this is nothing about this is normal so
I'm gonna be at least if I'm gonna be in
a hell a physical mental health or some
part of some fantasy attached to it by
the way this is not come from lawn
Harris it came from juju to 41 to 41
Spencer I'm a little upset that you
didn't use the term goop poop goop and
then you would eating goop poop let's
start with Dan Moreau that's why you're
upset
aside from the entire question this went
through my filter I was the ultimate
arbiter on putting this question the
speed around so I say to the audience to
them either
you're welcome or I'm sorry I Spencer
gave me a very well reasoned argument
based on the mechanics of the centipede
and while I acknowledge Kim's point of
view I think it is a much more
functional answer from Spencer so I'm
gonna go to flavortown with Spencer Guy
Fieri and Gwyneth Paltrow yes one Oh Ken
taking a much-needed drink after this
question Billy let's go with you brother
I mean Ken's logic was pretty sound as
well though I have to say like if you're
gonna be in the worst situation possible
I'm gonna let you decide this one how
I'm gonna give it to Ken to give you the
hard job dude what if I don't want to
decide this one we're all going down
together on this one you know what uh
there's no winners here how I'm I'm
gonna give it simply because I like the
idea of Spencer pooping and Guy Fieri's
[Laughter]
yep yep all right it is the score stands
at three two three two three all right
Ken needs this one if Spencer takes it
we're going home
all right but Spencer a winner all right
so here is question number three
they're both in Tarantino these actors
dig okay sorry I'm just tryna they're
both in Tarantino's new movie who do you
choose Leonardo DiCaprio or Brad Pitt
rip it I'm gonna give you Brad Pitt and
pig leave but who do you choose in what
sense I'm just reading what's in front
of it in a venue got ya all right
who you got who you want who you got
just slay me on the general question of
are you going with who you feel it he
went first all right all right here's
the thing he's 53 now I believe but
don't check me on that one I might be
wrong here's the thing you want to go
hang out in some faraway castle in the
hills in Hollywood that's Leo he never
comes back down the hill Brad Pitt and I
we're gonna hold hands we're gonna hug
we're gonna kiss we're gonna grab a
drink we're gonna head to the local
rouse and get a sandwich and eat in the
parking lot cuz that's I imagine deep
down what Brad Pitt is he is a he's a
great actor but I'm not intimidated
Leo's a better actor he knows who he is
he's just a guy who goes through models
like chewing gum he doesn't promise
Jennifer Aniston his heart and then
leave her betrayed for Angelina Jolie
and then even leave her standing a Brad
Pitt is a philanderer
but but Leo owns it and and he is who he
is he's comfortable with who he is he's
just the weird guy the courtside at
Laker games that you want to hang out
and have a beer with just waiting for
the right situation to come along that's
real life baby we're gonna head on down
to the Sunset Strip just probably some
pink taco restaurant and go sit down
some chips and salsa look at each
other's eyes that doesn't sound fun that
sounds sad and now I want to hang out
with Leo in between movies when he
really lets himself go and looks like a
hobo I think that's somebody that I
could really get along with you could
even go undercover without turning every
single head in the joint heavily all to
my side you know what I didn't know what
this question was
now I know exactly what it is that's
what Ken said yeah I want to eat a
sandwich with Brad Pitt no freaking
upper market parking how do you want to
call it that's what we're doing yeah
like that was a more vivid picture Dan
Laura I've been waiting for this since
the last drunk movie fights you are
wrong he's 50 for its age
notwithstanding I'm actually going with
Spencer let's go with the guy who owns
what he is let's do a hobo hangout with
Leo
I'm going with Spencer right so does
this sounds more fun to me
right on all right we are locked up at 1
1 Billie biz I mean I just like the the
image of because you had to stop I'm
just sitting there looking at each
other's eyes and some passionate staring
contest that just seems like more fun
Leo seems kind of stuck up to me that is
a bromance who's 54 I feel ashamed but
in the moment I read I await that first
fight was like two years ago all right
it all comes down to this the final
question of the speed round a great
moment in sports
who is the all-time greatest comedy
director
I'll tell Brooks yeah Ivan Reitman all
right
we have Mel Brooks we have Ivan Reitman
whoo let's slug it out Spencer you spoke
first you go first
Mel Brooks he's a master of satire he's
a master of buffoonery
he's a technically accomplished he can
imitate any style comfortably he's he's
an inimitable voice all of his
productions are zany but they're also
always his they always feel like a Mel
Brooks movie he puts his own signature
stamp on him from the dialog to the
performance to the subject matter he's
still subverting people after all these
years yeah Mel Brooks is great he's
absolutely he's great at being Mel
Brooks but I have a right mix movies
that have transcended the time and yeah
I'm Mel Brooks has too but people still
tried to make they try to make
ghostbusters better they try to make
these movies better and it's time to
what reitman did at his peak even say he
can subvert was something like a day
which is a political commentary and have
fun with that and Mel Brooks does great
at being Mel Brooks but everyone yeah
you throw out Dave you throw out
ghostbusters these are good comedies but
laugh for laugh we're talking comedy
here haha how many ha ha per second are
you getting out of a Mel Brooks movie
versus naive and reitman movie you are
laughing your ass off the rewatch
ability factor is off the charts
comedies perspective comedy is your
perspective that's hard to argue against
but like I would say ghostbusters is
more iconic to more generation since
something like Blazing Saddles for some
people are like what is that the cowboy
Ford picture let's start with Dan Merle
oh boy I mean yeah comedy is subjective
trying to say that phrase really fast it
is very difficult so you got to go I I
think we're Ken seemed a bit a bit
limited in his ability to paint out the
the film Agata the vastness of the
filmography of Ivan Reitman reitman I
thought Spencer did a better job of
painting out more of Mel Brooks's legacy
more of his work his tone etc I have to
go Spencer on this one all right that's
one Oh Spencer Billy biz yeah I'm gonna
echo that and I think Spencer really hit
like the laughs sperm
if it's best comedy I think you have to
go Mel Brooks I'll get the Spencer
Spencer jinx the day wow what a game
gentlemen I applaud you
you were down to oh and then you took it
to the max same back man and Mel Brooks
almost came out of my mouth there that
that name sounds oh but what a battle
what a battle you guys can watch you
plug some stuff tell us where to find yo
man I got a lot of things going on right
now you can follow me at catnaps up that
includes twitch where I stream games and
stuff talk Star Wars and wrestling in
life with you guys also got the podcast
and apps like files and my podcasts for
Center with Joseph scrimshaw Jennifer
landed we talked Star Wars four times a
week Spencer should come on
and can glad to have you back you're one
of our favorite folks so please come
back again maybe for a drunk movie
fights still have the belt it's locked
away in the car nice Spencer Congrats
well-played well-crafted arguments tell
us something you got going on plug
something I'll be here to the walls come
crashing down around us hell yeah uh
thanks man fun stuff today Dan Merle
thank you sir yeah I'll be holding up
the walls with Spencer
like like Luke and Han in the garbage
chute SiC reference Billy pissed thank
you for filling in for the inimitable
Daniel Radford today anything you want
to say to the folks out there actually
yeah right now over on screen junkies
news you can check it out we just posted
Roth and I we got to ask the hard
questions to the CEO of movie pass we
got to actually talk to him one-on-one
about the whole AMC thing blocking
theatres and he was surprisingly candid
so that's on screen junkies news
literally go click over right now wow it
sounds like you didn't give the CEO of
movie pass a free pass on that great I
want to thank you for watching movie
fights this is such a good time I'm Hal
Rudnick hit me up on Twitter Instagram
what else thanks for watching bye bye